when we were first exposed to
multiplication and division we saw that
they had an inverse relationship or
another way of thinking about is that
they can undo each other so for example
if I had two times four one
interpretation of this is I could have
four groups of two so that is one group
of two two groups of two three groups of
two and four groups of two and we
learned many many videos ago that this
of course is going to be equal to eight
but we could express a very similar idea
with division we could start with eight
things so let's start with one two three
four five six seven eight things so now
we're going to start with the eight and
we could say well let's try to divide
that into four groups four equal groups
well that's one equal group two equal
groups three equal groups and four equal
groups and we see when we take start
with eight divided into four equal
groups
each group is going to have two objects
in it so you probably see the
relationship 2 times 4 is 8 8 divided by
4 is 2 and actually if we did 8 divided
by 2 we would get 4 and this is
generally true if I have something times
something else is equal to whatever
their product is if you take the product
and divide by one of those two numbers
you will get the other one and that idea
applies to fractions and it actually
makes a lot of sense with fractions so
for example let's say that we started
off with one-third one-third and we
wanted to multiply that times 3 x 3 well
there's a couple of ways we could
visualize it actually let me just draw a
diagram here so let's say that this
block represents a hole and let me shade
in 1/3 of it let me shade it in 1/3 of
it
so that's 1/3 we're going to multiply by
3 so we're going to have 3 of these 1
thirds or another way of thinking about
is going to be 1/3 x or 1/3 plus another
1/3 plus another 1/3 that's our first
third our
second third and our third third and we
get the whole this is 3/3 or one so this
is going to be equal to one so you use
the exact same idea if one-third times
three is equal to one then that means
that 1/3 that 1/3 must be equal to
one-third must be equal to one-third and
this comes straight out of how we first
even thought about fractions the first
way that we we ever thought about
fractions was well let's start with a
hole and that hole would be our 1 and
let's divide it into 3 equal sections
the same way that we divided this eight
into four equal groups so if you divide
this into three equal sections the size
of each of those sections is going to be
exactly is going to be exactly 1/3 now
this leads to an interesting question
that might be popping in your brain
notice we have 1 as the numerator 3 is a
denominator and we just said that this
is equal to the numerator divided by the
denominator 1 over 3 is the same thing
as 1 divided by 3 is this always true
for a fraction well let's just do the
same thought experiment but let's do it
with a different fraction let's try
let's try let's take three-fourths and
multiply it by 4 so multiply it by 4 so
once again let's see if I could draw a
fourth here let me do this in a new
color
so I'll take let's say that this block
right over here is a whole I'm going to
divide it into four equal sections so
now I've divided into four it's and let
me copy and paste it so I can use it
multiple times so copy all right now 3/4
that's going to be why we could assume I
didn't draw it perfect actually I could
draw it a little bit better than that
just to make the three the four equal
sections actually look equal so that
looks like a little bit better of a job
I'm trying to make them four equal
sections and let me copy that one so let
me use it for later
now 3/4 this is four equal sections and
three fourths represents three of them
one
two three but now we're going to
multiply it by four so we're going to
have three fourths or times so we're
going to need some more holes here so
let's throw in another hole so this is
one 3/4 now let me do the next 3/4 in
another color so this is another that's
1/4 that's the second fourth that's a
third fourth
that's another 3/4 and now let's do so
we've done two 3/4 just now let me make
it clear this is the first 3/4 and then
this plus this is the second 3/4 now
let's do a third 3/4 and we're going to
have to neat we're going to have to use
a few we're going to have to use another
hole right over here and I will do that
in this color so my third 3/4 so here's
a fourth here's my second fourth here's
a third fourth so in green I have
another 3/4 and now we need for 3/4 so
let's do that in a color I have not used
yet maybe white so that's 1/4 that's two
forts and that is 3/4 so notice now I
have now I have one 3/4 to 3/4 three 3/4
and for 3/4 and what did I do when I got
those for 3/4 well it's pretty clear
this is turned into three wholes
so this is equal to three wholes
well if 3/4 times four is equal to 3
that means that 3/4 3/4 is equal to 3/4
is equal to 3/4 so the same idea again 3
over 4 is the same thing as 3/4 and in
general this is true the the fraction
symbol here can be interpreted as
division and looking at this diagram
right here it make complete sense if you
started with three wholes and you want
to divide it into four equal groups one
group two groups three groups four
groups each group is going to be 3 is
going to have three
Forte's in it